residents in china's financial hub say
they're going hungry
[Music]
[Applause]
many people have been unable to leave
their homes to buy food since late march
[Applause]
that's because shanghai officials began
a citywide lockdown to tame the
country's biggest coven 19 outbreak in
the past two years
some residents have also taken to social
media to complain
it has prompted a lot of people in
shanghai to ask
is this the right policy is the cost of
this lockdown
too great
as authorities try to tame the fast
spreading omicron variant the growing
public discontent could challenge
beijing's commitment to its dynamic zero
copied policy
[Music]
shanghai officials have acknowledged its
strategy of lockdowns mass tests and
quarantines has made it difficult for
tens of thousands of families to secure
food so they rolled out a massive effort
to deliver necessities
[Music]
local officials said there were around
11 000 couriers on the job and delivery
companies had about 100 000 other
workers
volunteers have also been going door to
door to deliver other supplies including
medicine
plus people from across the country have
been pitching in including from as far
as xinjiang where workers package bread
for residents
there's also fresh vegetables coming
from shanghai's neighboring province
but some residents have said that
they're not getting enough food from
these deliveries there are some people
who are doing okay but there's also
unquestionably people who are living on
basically the barest minimum of food
with no protein and very little in terms
of quantity for instance a family of two
received this package from the
government on the second day of the
lockdown the father and daughter said it
was all consumed in about four days and
the next delivery came about two weeks
later
so to feed themselves some people are
getting up as early as 6 am to place an
order on grocery delivery apps at a time
when supplies are more likely to be
available
this man's wife recorded him using a
massage gun to help him more quickly hit
the pay button to get his order through
before others
some residents have teamed up with
neighbors to buy in bulk we've got over
150 parcels in here
we ordered for the whole building again
or they're bartering with each other
the struggle to get food has sparked
anger in some communities
this video was posted on wei bull
china's equivalent of twitter and it was
later taken down it shows local police
trying to contain a crowd of people
weibo didn't respond to a request for
comment
these food shortages have largely
stemmed from the city's strict covid
restrictions which have confined many of
the city's food delivery workers at home
and some have chosen not to work for
fear of getting sick
also for new supplies to enter the city
truck drivers need to test negative once
you come into the city and you've
delivered your supplies it's not clear
if you can necessarily get into the
neighboring province to be able to pick
up another run of supplies because the
authorities won't
necessarily allow you into the province
because you've just come from a high
risk zone
shanghai officials have pledged to do
better
however the anxiety of not having enough
to eat is raising some collective
memories from china's famine about five
decades ago china's modern history has
had a lot of instances of deprivation
and of quite serious lack of access to
food this is a 21st century twist on
that but it has reminded people of the
importance of having stockpiles
and the situation in shanghai has
prompted some people in other cities to
prepare for the worst on weibo the topic
what to prepare if i suddenly receive a
quarantine notice has attracted more
than 200 million views
and chinese state media published this
diagram which outlines the items you
need to prepare to stay at a quarantine
center
even though shanghai officials announced
that they have lifted some measures
despite record cases people have started
to question more than just the
government's handling of the food
shortage
there is a great degree of
dissatisfaction about whether or not
it's the wisest way to deal with this
challenge this dynamic zero coveted
policy of really just trying to
eradicate the virus every time they see
it anywhere within china if it ends up
overwhelming shanghai it's going to
challenge that idea that china's
government has been more successful than
the rest of the world that containing
kovit but the experience in shanghai
hasn't prompted any indication from
beijing that it's ready to rethink its
covet strategy the head of china's coven
19 response task force said its dynamic
zero coveted policy was scientific and
would bring maximum results
so with little sign that beijing is
willing to adjust its pandemic strategy
some residents have taken to their
balconies
to shout encouragement and hope that the
lockdown ends soon
[Music]